so today we're going to talk about why
you lost your butt yet you gained a
belly
and there's some data i want to share in
this book right here the siba collection
of medical illustrations
volume 4 endocrine system on page
okay this is the picture of someone with
too much cortisol cortisol if excessive
can break down the quads
and the glutamus maximus right here so
let me just explain and i'm not trying
to diagnose you with that condition
which is called cushing's syndrome
because you don't just one day wake up
with cushing's syndrome which is a high
level of cortisol it happens gradually
so you can have a version of that but
not a full-blown cushing's disease
just because of high cortisol so since
cortisol is a stress and a survival
hormone what it tends to do is
keep your sugar levels available so you
can use it as quick energy and also it
will rob peter to pay paul it will take
um extra things from your body that you
might not need or you have extra like
the gluteus maximus is the largest
muscle in the body so apparently it has
extra amino acids to convert over into
glucose then you have the next largest
muscle which is the thigh muscle the
quadricep so both of these muscles are
then broken down and that process is a
catabolic effect catabolic means you're
breaking down something from protein to
amino acid and then from amino acid to
glucose in the process you're developing
also atrophy of the muscles which could
look like cellulite but it's really not
it's just a loss of muscle fiber
so we get muscle
amino acids
sugar glucose and then that's converted
to fat with the help of
insulin
so now the question is what causes this
condition and then of course what can we
do about it
well there's several things it could be
that you're on prednisone because you
have some type of inflammatory condition
that's basically a synthetic version of
cortisol and one of the side effects is
cushing's syndrome which is that high
cortisol
now when a woman goes through menopause
they will lose
the ovary function or to some degree not
but there's a backup organ called the
adrenals so if you go into menopause
with
adrenal weakness or adrenal stress
then you can develop a higher level of
cortisol because the adrenals are now
coping with that extra function and that
can affect a lot of things it can affect
the loss of collagen in your joints
even you can have bone loss because
there's less
protein in the bone itself but also this
is probably why you see a lot of women
after menopause that
lose the butt in the quads and then we
just have a situation where you go
through chronic stress for a period of
time that can do it or let's say you
have a tumor on either the adrenal gland
or the pituitary gland that can also do
it birth control pills this is
interesting birth control pills has many
side effects one being
pseudo cushing's now what is pseudo
cushing's well it's not necessarily
coming from the same mechanism it's
coming from a different mechanism where
there is an increase of something called
cortical steroid binding globulin now
what does that mean that means that
where there's an increase of this thing
in your liver called
cbg okay cortical steroid binding
globulin and what the heck is that
that is
a combination of protein connected to
cortisol so in other words about 90
percent of all the cortisol in the body
is bound to a protein and so that way
it's not free it's not available and we
have similar mechanisms for testosterone
and estrogen as well
but we don't necessarily want all this
free
cortisol in the body so we have to
put it in an inactive or a bound state
to protein well the problem is birth
control pills increases
this cbg
thereby increasing cortisol okay now you
also see this same mechanism in
pregnancy
it probably could also happen if you are
on some type of estrogen therapy as in
hormone replacement therapy possibly or
even possibly if you're estrogen
dominant okay for some reason
the more fat that you have in your body
both men and women the more estrogen
you'll have because the fat cell
makes more estrogen but i didn't include
that because there's not a lot of
research on that topic
now there are other things that are not
related to necessarily cortisol
that can create atrophy of your butt and
your thigh okay like one would be
sarcopenium now what is a sarcopenia
that is a condition where you're just
losing muscle mass and strength with age
okay
and i have done a video on that and i
will put a link down below so that's one
cause you're just getting older
but there's things you can do to counter
that inactivity so if you're sitting all
day you have a desk job uh and you have
no exercise well
this is the body shape that you're gonna
get
or let's say you have chronic low back
pain that prevents you from
activating these muscles and that could
do it as well so
what is the solution
right here
if you are on prednisone you want to
find an alternative okay
and
i don't know what reason you'd be on
prednisone for whatever reason i would
there's a lot of different alternatives
in fact i do have a video on that and i
will put that down below but typically
there's always an herbal or some natural
solution to whatever medication you're
taking of course check with your doctor
like adaptogens for example like
ashwagandha
is a great
stress reducer and it can greatly
support your adrenals the gland behind
the cortisol
also vitamin d is a natural
anti-inflammatory a very potent and
powerful one and it's great for pain so
if you're taking prednisone
for that reason maybe you should try
something a little different
all right number two reduce your stress
so whatever the source of your stress is
do whatever you can
to
reduce the stress
doing physical work is one of the best
remedies for overall mental stress it
takes your mind off things and it works
your physical body and of course
exercise itself is great for stress
especially long walks or any type of
exercise as long as you avoid over
training which is not good for high
cortisol number three if you get on the
ketogenic diet with intermittent fasting
you're going to reduce
the flight or fight mechanism the
sympathetics and increase the
parasympathetic nervous system okay that
can help lower cortisol
and this is why when people go on keto
and if they don't feel as anxious
anymore
they feel better less depressed so it
can actually change your whole mood
number four the key nutrients that you
need to help
balance and reduce cortisol
potassium eat foods high in potassium or
find a potassium supplement potassium is
a natural physiological tranquilizer it
relaxes the muscles it calms down your
body also magnesium
very very important just so happens that
potassium magnesium are in leafy greens
like in large amounts of salad
b1 which i like to get from nutritional
yeast also is one of the best natural
things to lower cortisol you'll feel the
difference you take it like in a form of
nutritional yeast and you wait like four
minutes you just
wow it just gives you relief
um
all right so now we have sleep of course
that is vitally important because the
less sleep you have the more cortisol
you have the worse the blood sugars i
have a ton of videos on that which i'll
put some important ones down below and
then number six limit the amount of
things that stimulate the adrenals like
caffeine like tea
like chocolate like um energy drinks all
that will prevent you from sleeping and
there's one last point that is
kind of invisible
emf electromagnetic fields from your
cell phone from the computer i bought a
tester okay i did a video on this
i found that sitting behind a computer
for i don't know how many hours i mean
probably 14 hours a day i was being
bathed in electromagnetic fields which
when i
completely rearranged my computer and
things i felt an instant drop in stress
so i think this has a really big factor
you should watch the video i did on this
because it's an invisible
stressor
that is so common yet it's not really
mentioned hardly anywhere so i'm going
to put that video up right here check it
out
you